Now before we can get started working on our landscapes
We need to make sure that we are set up for success from the beginning
And that's why we're going to cover in this part our initial project setup
And the first thing that we're going to talk about in our initial project setup is actually creating a brand new project
So what we're gonna do is from the unreal project browser
We're gonna select the game section and then from the game section
We're gonna select the third person template leaving all of the project defaults settings enabled
Give it a name advanced landscapes and press the create button. So let's go ahead and follow along and do that now
So again, we're gonna click on games
Make sure that third person is selected leaving everything over here and the project defaults at its default setting and give this a name of
Advanced landscapes. We are then going to hit the create button and while that creates
Let's go ahead and talk about what we're gonna do once the editor launches
And the first thing is we're gonna enable the landscape patch plugin
This is a really cool plugin that allows you to place a
Actor underneath another actor that will affect the landscape and this effectively allows you to make
foundations for buildings
so that when you place this building into a level that has landscape the landscape will be
Deformed or brought up or down to match that level and this is really really powerful because this means that you don't have to
Actually hand paint anything when it comes to your landscape in terms of adding buildings or objects
That need to sit on top of it
So now that our editor has opened let's go ahead and bring it on screen and we're gonna come up here to edit
Plugins and then we're gonna search for our L a n D and then right there
There's our landscape patch. Now when we click this it is gonna give us a warning message
So we're gonna click yes to this and before we hit restart now, we need to do a few other things
So I'm actually gonna close the plugins. We're gonna pop back over here to our presentation
And the next thing that we are going to be doing is we're gonna come over to our project settings and we're gonna enable
Virtual texturing support now virtual texturing does a number of really great things in terms of performance
But when it comes to open worlds
Especially making advanced landscapes. We need this virtual texture support enabled so that we can build the world partition mini-map
So let's go ahead and do that now by coming back over here to the editor
we're gonna come up here to edit and then we're gonna go to project settings and
Then we're gonna scroll down here on the left-hand side
Under engine looking for the rendering section and once we've clicked on rendering
We're then gonna scroll down a little bit more until we locate our virtual textures
And then we have this enable virtual texture support. So we're gonna go ahead and click that on
now we do need to restart the editor, but
We actually need to do one other thing. So what I'm gonna do is instead of restarting it
I'm first gonna hit ctrl space and then I'm just gonna come in here and grab this characters folder right click on it and
Show an explorer and I'm gonna pull this up
the reason that we want to do this is because our next option that we want to enable is going to be
Involving configuring one of our ini files
So in order to get the displacement to work for nanite tessellation
We need to open up our default engine ini file locate our script slash engine dot rendering settings and then input the following
two commands r dot nanite dot allow tessellation equal to one and r dot nanite dot
tessellation equal to one so again, what I did here is I right-clicked
Found this an explorer so that when I close this down what's gonna happen here is that's gonna make this
Just a little bit easier to come back up here to our advanced landscapes
And so we're in our unreal engine 5 projects advanced landscapes
We're gonna look for our config folder and then we want our default engine dot ini
So we're gonna open that up and then right under here is our script engine rendering settings
So right down here at the bottom. This is where we're going to input those two commands
So I am just gonna copy these from off-screen here
Just give me one
Second and then I will leave this up for everybody to have a look at so that you can copy it as well
So again, there's r dot nanite dot allow tessellation equal to one and r dot nanite dot
tessellation equal to one when you're done
It's very important that you save this file. All right, so I've saved this so I'm gonna go ahead and close this down
I'm gonna close this down and I will leave this up on the screen for a few more
Moments, so you can go ahead and add this to your project and remember make sure you save this file once that's done
And then we're gonna restart our project as well
So have a look at this restart the editor and we'll be back in just a moment
Alright now that we are back
What we're gonna do now is we're gonna check our project to make sure that everything is working
So I'm gonna bring the editor back on screen here and first things first
I'm gonna hit ctrl space and then inside of our content here
I'm just gonna right click and look for a
Material and I'm not gonna name it because we're just gonna be checking this to see and we're gonna delete this in a second
So we're just gonna double click on it to open it up
And what we want to look for is we want to see this displacement right here now displacement is gonna be grayed out
So in order to ungrade that out if we come over here in the details panel
We can enable tessellation and there we go
We've got our displacement working so we can verify that that is working and I'm gonna hit ctrl space and I'm just gonna delete this
Because it's no longer needed
So the next thing that we need to do is we're gonna come down here to our starter content and to our textures
And we're just gonna right click on any texture and we're gonna look for this convert to virtual texture this
Signifies that virtual texture support is enabled in our project. So we are good there
Now the last thing that we need to check is our landscape
Height map plugins for our circle height patch and our texture patch. So we're just gonna select an actor
We're gonna come up here to our ad that you can find in the details panel
And then we're just gonna search for LA and D. There we go
So we see our landscape circle height patch and our landscape texture patch. So those things are working
So that's good. Everything that we need is
There so next what we're gonna do is we're gonna get some content and first things first
We are going to import some
Brushes that we're gonna use later on in this tutorial to help affect the landscape and in order to make everything nice and neat
We're gonna put these into a new folder called brushes. So let's go ahead and do that now
So let's pop over to the editor. We're gonna hit ctrl space on the keyboard come up to content right click new folder
I'm gonna call this brushes
Now with today's class there should have been some files that you received as well and inside there
we're gonna have this textures folder and we are gonna take these impact craters and this tea mountain and go ahead and bring those in to
our brushes folder here just by simply dragging and dropping them from their spot and windows into the
Content browser. Let's go ahead and save this
Fantastic, and then next what we're gonna do is we are going to go to the quixel store as
well as the
Unreal Engine
launcher and download and add the following
Assets to our project. So we're gonna add the temperate vegetation spruce forest and
we're also going to add the
Kiki-ku. I'm not really sure how to say that grass and the Donnie willow
So I'm gonna leave this on screen for just a moment
Feel free to pause the video here while you search for this inside of the epic games launcher
You can find the temperate vegetables in the earth the temperate vegetation
I'm sorry in the epic games launcher and these other two objects will be found inside of
Quixel and if you're unsure how to do this remember our ad we come up here to add to Quixel and then we can search
Through our Quixel bridge here for those assets
And the other way that we do this is we come up to our epic games
Launcher here we can go to the marketplace and we'll give this a second to load here and then we can look for
There we go. And there it is right there temper
vegetation spruce forest we just would add this to our project and
Once we have added those
The next thing that we're going to add is the following
Surfaces that can be found inside of the Quixel
Bridge plug-in
So if you input rocky ground and then the names that you see underneath each one of these you will find these exact
Textures now you don't have to use these exact textures
You can use something that is similar. But these are the ones that are being used inside of this video tutorial series
So these are the ones you'd most likely want to use if you want to follow along one-to-one
so I will leave this up on the screen for a little bit and
Once you have all of this
Selected you'll be ready to start our next section which is going to be landscape material creation